pudo ser un fallo que podría haber
proporcionado un precedente legal a las
víctimas civiles de la guerra de vietnam
todos los ojos estaban puestos en parís
este lunes tras la demanda de trato nia
de 79 años contra 14 multinacionales la
franco-vietnamita alegaba que gigantes
químicos como monsanto y down que me cal
ahora parte del grupo bayer le causaron
graves daños corporales a ella a sus
hijos y a otras personas al proporcionar
al ejército de eeuu el agente naranja un
herbicida que los militares usaban para
limpiar cultivos y también para revelar
las posiciones enemigas
en las que tuve una nube cayó de un
avión
7 una nube espesa casi de aspecto
grasiento que descendió rápidamente
y un líquido pegajoso me mojo el cuerpo
y me hizo toser mucho
póngase
sanz fitoussi boku entre 1962 y 1971
eeuu arrojó aproximadamente 80 millones
de litros de agente naranja en vietnam
suficiente para llenar 32 piscinas
olímpicas pero la mezcla contenía
dioxinas sustancias químicas altamente
tóxicas y que pueden provocar cáncer y
defectos físicos al nacer millones de
vietnamitas se vieron afectados
incluidos 150.000 niños nacidos con
defectos genéticos graves pero para la
demandante se trata de algo personal la
exposición a la gente le provocó una
serie de problemas de salud incluidos
diabetes y cáncer e incluso se cobró la
vida de su hijo que murió de una
malformación cardíaca cuando tenía
apenas unos meses la mujer dice que
presentó la demanda por sus hijos y los
millones de víctimas hasta ahora sólo
los veteranos militares de eeuu
australia y corea han ganado una
compensación por las secuelas del
químico